[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with columnist at the article
ali mirage and journalist and author
christina patterson evening to you both
let's take a look now at what's on some
of those front pages
the sunday telegraph claims that boris
johnson has been warned the migrant
crisis could destroy the conservative
party as a poll for the paper shows the
majority of tory voters believe the
government's approach to channel
crossings is too soft
the health secretary has ordered a
review into racial bias in medical
equipment reports the sunday times
because of fears thousands of ethnic
minority patients who died of covid
should have survived
senior conservatives say the party is
risking a rebellion if boris johnson
doesn't ditch plans that would see many
of england's poorest pensioners paying
more for their social care that's
according to the observer
the sunday mirror also leads with the
prime minister featuring a picture of
him without a face mask on a northern
train
and loyal redwall tory mps are still
backing winner boris johnson to lead
them into the next election says the
sunday express
and we're joined tonight by ali mirage
and christina patterson evening to you
both great to see you
so ali let's start with you and the
front of the sunday telegraph boris
johnson under increasing pressure over
the migrant crisis
well this is the story sarah that's been
rumbling on for some time now uh there
have been 24
500 migrants that have crossed the
channel so far
this year and they're averaging about a
thousand a day now so this is a really
serious problem it has been a headache
for the home secretary for some time now
but unfortunately despite various
measures being taken uh we're failing to
get a grip of it she's looked at
potentially sending
migrants to um
ascension island that was dropped hiring
special equipment to make bigger waves
to try and push them back towards france
that was dropped she's uh got 54 million
that she's giving to the french state to
try and help with these border controls
to increase drone patrols and
surveillance but it's still not having
enough of an impact
and this is now as is um the story
saying there that 77 of tory voters are
really feeling that this is hampering
the popularity of the government and
donors certain tory donors are now
coming out saying that the prime
minister needs to get really tough on
this or it could destabilize um the
prospects of a tory victory at the next
election so it's a serious problem the
prime minister's drafted in steve
barclay the cabinet office minister to
help pretty patel with this to underline
the severity of the issue but it's
difficult to see exactly what could
happen there was some talk of asylum
seekers being processed in albania
earlier this week which the albanian
government immediately um sort of put
into the long grass so not really sure
what's going to happen there i think
they've been talks with about six other
countries as well but nothing has
actually been agreed so far so a real
issue for the government and one that's
costing it popularity right now yeah i
mean home secretary after home secretary
has grappled with this issue we've had a
lot of tough talk from uh pretty patel
as ali has just set out there christina
but what is the pm going to do now under
pressure and is it going to make any
difference
i imagine he's going to promise to send
them to mars to be processed because i
think that's that's the kind of promise
he makes and that's probably about as
much as you can trust any of his
promises i mean this is a kind of
absolutely typical of this government
that they think everything is easy they
they promise that they will solve this
problem and that problem i mean we went
through a whole national disaster
essentially brexit complete act of
self-sabotage and economic self-harm
under the illusion delusion that it
would enable us to have control over our
own borders and what this shows is that
you know there is literally nobody
except us uh stopping us from um
controlling our borders now and we can't
do it because uh we are much better or
our government is much better at coming
up with empty slogans than enacting any
kind of policy of course this is a
complex issue there are things that
could be done and it's interesting that
the
uh
tory voters are saying that the
government is too soft actually what it
is is incompetent it's been in power for
you know 11 years and uh what it ends up
with is just a mess
most asylum games are not not sorted out
for years
and pretty patel's been in washington
this week she's been speaking she's been
pointing the finger at schengen at the
open borders policy in in europe as
being to blame for this but there is a
lot of pressure ali isn't there coming
from within the tory party and from
outside a prominent party donor quoted
in the telegraph but also cabinet
ministers um saying the government is
shot and bereft of ideas and like a dead
man walking according to the telegraph
well look i think what uh what what
people want within the tory party is a
bit like uh as one uh tory backbencher
told me boris got brexit done we want
him to get boats done
and that's what they want the reality is
that it's um it's very difficult to do
and i think the home secretary needs to
be careful i mean talking about schengen
which is a an operation a a protocol
that's been in place since 1995 it's a
bit odd to be blaming schengen for this
issue right now uh look it is a serious
issue and you've now got uh increased
migrants now um on the border at poland
as well which is a crisis being
confected by uh the bella russian state
so there are problems but this comes at
a time sarah where the government has
had really a lot of self-inflicted
problems uh the most notable one being
the whole handling of the owen patterson
uh outside interests uh row which then
mushroomed on for two weeks into a much
broader issue around second jobs for mps
totally self-inflicted where the prime
minister this week did show contrition
rightly so in front of the 1922
committee of conservative back benches
but a lot of people shaking their heads
within the party thinking well why did
that have to happen
a serious issue then there was also
disappointment around the hs2 uh the
fact that the eastern line has been
scrapped the fact that the trans-pennine
route between leeds and manchester will
not go ahead so some uh backbenchers
particularly from the 29 intake in the
red wall feeling hard done by feeling
that leveling up is not what it actually
is all made out to be and over promising
and under delivering so i think the
prime minister's got some problems on
various flanks and this is a very
visible headache one of the key issues
for getting brexit done was to control
the borders and to control migration if
this visibly cannot be seen to be done
so openly and patently with people
landing on the shores every day it's a
really bad look for the government well
let's look at another of those headaches
uh for the prime minister on the front
of the observer at christina and
social care plans
yes well um what has emerged this week
after great flourishing announcements
about uh social care was going to be
done as well and sorted a problem that
has been hanging around for a very long
time is that level up leveling up now
appears to be leveling down yet again
which is what generally happens in this
country because the social care policy
that's been unveiled would penalize
poorer pensioners much more than richer
pension is they would pay a much higher
proportion of their of their assets to
contribute to their social care so
understandably this is going down like a
bucket of sick with red wall mps already
very very fed up with the prime minister
because as ali says because of his
handling of the owen patterson affair
and it's it's very interesting that
people say things like boris johnson was
badly advised over that i mean how
do you really have to be advised to that
tearing up a rule book in the middle of
a process is a bad idea i mean that
stank everybody could see it stank boris
johnson couldn't see it stank because he
does now admit doesn't need that he made
a big mistake
yeah sure because it's backfired but is
he sorry no he's just sorry that he was
caught out he's sorry that it's had uh
ill consequences for him and he's not a
man who's used to dealing with
consequences he's a man who's used to
tearing up the rulebook wherever he goes
and thinking it would all be fine and
now he's thought oh dear i've been
caught out and this is very very
inconvenient for me and i'm afraid the
social care thing is likely to backfire
in a similar way because people are not
going to back this and mps now have got
the taste of rebellion because you know
they're not going to be automatically
doing what they're told to do so i think
i think we could well be seeing yet
another u-turn from this government of
constant u-turns ali he's also been
caught without a mask on a train on the
front of the sunday mirror
yeah it's just not helpful i mean the
prime minister is his own worst enemy
look if anyone could lose the next
election
and boris uh is a is a politician that
defies political gravity uh he wears his
political clothing very lightly he's the
teflon politician and he's a winner
which is why the conservatives backed
him and they'll continue to back him
while they think he's going to win as
soon as they don't think he's going to
win things will get very difficult for
him so he is the he's the single person
who can actually uh point his own gun
towards his own foot and shoot himself
um
in the foot uh ahead of the next
election and just little things like
this i mean earlier this week
he went on a visit to a hospital where
again uh he didn't wear a mask for part
of the visit
apparently not for very long but still
why put oneself in that position to be
ridiculed like this
little things and you know a lot of
people criticize dominic cummings for
the way that he ran the downhill street
operation but he did speak truth to
power he was very very direct and tough
with his boss and the problem is in
cryptic christina's point
i really do feel that in downing street
right now there seems to be a lack of
key advisors that can actually tell the
prime minister prime minister if you do
x uh if you take x position it's a very
very bad idea it's gonna back fire and
you're now in a position where
as christina says you've got a number of
back benches that are very very wary on
this social care point they're not going
to just take a three-line whip and get
told what to do they're going to push
back and say look hang on a second we've
had so many u-turns so we've been
embarrassed in front of our constituents
over this whole climb down on second
jobs we're just not going to be lobby
fodder anymore we're going to push back
and that's very dangerous in terms of
party management for a government
okay let's take a pause
coming up after the break could you be
one of the many people experiencing hogo
as a result of the pandemic you can find
out what that means after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me are the economist at the
article ali mirage and journalist and
author christina patterson christina the
front of the sunday times now and it has
a story with the health secretary sajid
javid
looking into one of the issues that has
been much discussed during coronavirus
and why ethnic minorities were
disproportionately affected by the virus
what is he trying to find out
well according to this story it's less
the overall issue of why death rates
amongst uh black and ethnic minority
people were so shockingly high as
compared to
white caucasian people this is actually
about medical equipment and whether
there is bias and medical equipment
because apparently oximeters which are
very important in measuring oxygen
levels for patients with covid are less
accurate for black people than they are
for white people now this is actually
part i think of a much wider issue i've
done some um i've written a wrote a
report for an organization called
alzheimer's disease international a few
years ago and one of the things i
learned is that a lot of um most medical
trials are done more on white people
than
bime people for all kinds of reasons
because of the people who volunteer the
people who come forward so it is a
complex issue and you know clearly it's
good that sergey javed is looking into
this but the much much bigger issue is
why two to four times as many um black
and ethnic minority patients died than
white people and there are lots of
reasons for that but one is
clearly that there are you know many
come from levels areas with high levels
of deprivation because essentially
poorer people generally have paid the
price for this pandemic which has been
tragic so it is a complex issue but i
remember in the early days when the
photos popped up healthcare workers who
had died and the shock when you realized
that they were nearly all brown
essentially and one of the things that
emerged at that point was that for some
reason healthcare workers whether
doctors um healthcare workers nurses or
whoever
seemed to have less access to ppe than
white healthcare workers now that is an
absolute scandal and again it's one of
the things that needs to be looked into
and on this specifically ali these
devices people will recognize and they
go on the end of your finger
and they might measure oxygen levels in
your blood and the thinking is that
because dark skin absorbs more light
than white skin they may not be so
accurate is that right
that's right that's what's being
reported in the paper and i think sergio
jarvis right too
to investigate it further i mean clearly
if there are deficiencies in design
which are not accurately giving you uh
readings upon which uh various uh
medical decisions are then made there is
a problem uh so i do think it's right to
look at it and i think uh i think i
think the health secretary
should uh hopefully get to the bottom of
what the issue is and try and resolve it
yeah and devices have been in use since
the 1980s
in fact let's have a look at the uh
sunday telegraph uh ali with you then
and this is about the rollout of
vaccinations uh to younger age group
children and whether or not they should
be rolled out to five-year-olds
well yes this is a talk about uh
whether whether we should be rolling out
jabs to kids between the ages of 5 and
11.
not because they are particularly
affected badly adversely by coronavirus
i think there are literally a handful of
fatalities amongst kids thankfully on
the back of coronavirus but more because
they can act as
vectors for the spread of infection and
at the moment it's all about third
booster jabs for adults and also trying
to
keep the transmission under control so
that the nhs is not overwhelmed and the
death rate remains low which thankfully
at the moment we seem to be managing and
containing so that's what it's around i
think the the royal college of um
pediatricians is not convinced by this
it wants a lot more discussion around it
a lot it wants a lot more evidence
around it because these uh decisions are
very finely judged and you do not want
to be administering vaccines to kids
where there really is not compelling
evidence uh suggests there are no
negative effects uh in the long term and
there just simply isn't enough evidence
yet so i think this one's gonna run for
a little while longer yeah i mean it's a
similar discussion to that we had before
the decision to roll out the vaccines to
the 12 to 15
year old bracket as well and coming as
uh we start to see boosters opened up to
the over 40s and second doses for 16 and
17 year olds as of uh next week before
we run out of time christina uh let's go
back to the sunday times do you suffer
from hogo
what i suffer from hogo is um the hassle
of going out which is where for example
book restaurants and then don't turn up
for them or book theater tickets even
and don't turn up for them and i
certainly don't do that but what i
suffer from if i'm honest is really
really intense nostalgia for my life as
it was before the pandemic i'm someone
most of my adult life i've been out most
nights and i've now had you know
something like whatever it is i've lost
track like 500 nights of mostly sitting
at home which is not my idea of a great
time so i don't have a fear of the
hassle of going out what i do have is a
fear of catching covid um because as we
know it's an airborne disease and if you
go to restaurants or theatres where
obviously you know people are not
wearing masks in restaurants and some
people may be vaccinated some may not
but even if you are vaccinated doesn't
stop you getting or spreading the virus
so
for the moment i'm erring on the side of
caution but i'm really really sick of
hearing on the side of caution i would
much rather be out you know going to
parties dancing doing whatever doing
whatever i used to do but um but i have
some sympathy for those who have got out
of the habit and find that they they
just you know have kind of lost that
habit or muscle as a psychologist who's
interviewed for this piece has said i'm
in awe of your stamina to have been out
every night at christina are you a
fellow party animal ali
uh you know i'm a party i know i i i dj
a lot but i've also been eating out a
lot in restaurants i took rishi sunak's
instruction last year eat out to help
out
really to heart even though the
government is no longer subsidizing my
my dinners which is reflected in my
waistline so no i don't have
any sort of hassle of going out issues i
much prefer going to restaurants and
sitting at home watching squid games on
netflix not that there's anything wrong
with that um but i look i yearn to meet
people and i i'm enjoying going out and
about going to the theaters and also
going to art galleries and eating out
and enjoying myself so yes i don't have
this issue well i suppose we should say
a very big thank you then for staying in
on your saturday night to join us here
on sky news we will see you again in the
next hour